matthew rockland awesome awesome guy
contributes to sin pi just got snagged
by continuum and he's going to talk to
you today about functional performance
with core data structures give me a hand
hi everyone thanks for coming I said my
name is Matthew Rockland and you're
talking about functional for once with
core data structures uh the question uh
you can't hear someone can't hear we've
all you be changed seven else okay Oh a
little bladder though great thank you
all right um disclaimer this talk has
its benchmark Senate and benchmarks you
shouldn't trust it's also sort of a new
thing so people haven't ripped into this
yet so it's experimental don't uh don't
touch too harshly ok so the synopsis is
I'm going to claim that pure python is
not always slow slow many cases but not
always slow and we don't want to sort of
make that always claim and then python
is a decent functional language so talk
a little bit functional programming not
too much so it won't be won't be scary
functional programming I promise okay so
we have this intuition that python is a
slow language and you know so here's
majors multiply written in Python pure
python no fancy that surround it and and
it is slow you know you should not be
measurable to flies in Python it's sort
of 10 or 100 x slow down when we use
Python over some see some SI system of
course are all of all are very nice see
systems that we can use looking the
Python so that's sort of one we usually
think a python is being slow so we're
going to see and it's one story for
numerics but that benchmark was it was a
numeric benchmark and I claim that we
often take that intuition and we apply
to other cases where it doesn't apply so
what about all the other cases what over
not doing numerics is Python still slow
so the question I want to ask okay again
this talk has benchmarks in it micro
benchmarks micro benchmarks are hard to
do well you can render them pretty
easily they're intended to sort of just
give an idea so don't
just everything to sort of take ideas
away for best performance I should
understand your problem that's always
the best thing okay so one thing Python
performance has going for it is idea
that its core data structures are
actually very very fast this see the
Python [ __ ] is often cited in
scholarly articles as an awesome debt so
you'll actually find it in native C code
you'll find C code that imports the
Python [ __ ] and uses it despite not
being in Python at all so python is
really a core data structures going for
it so here's my my common little
benchmark to show off the speed of fun
data structures here's the frequencies
function we're just we have some
collection we want to count how many
times each element in that collection
occurred so here we have we have some
some list of names if we make it sort of
long artificially we call frequencies
alone accounts we often do computations
like this the sort of the basic
competition that's hard to do
numerically unless you know your data
ahead of time as we can ask you know how
long does that take we had how many
elements we have we had about seven
million we can count them in a lot a
second that's just naive Python code
it's not see based or anything when I
bring up frequencies people always tell
me about the counter object and
collections in the standard library
that's actually a lot slower than just
naive Python what they're doing other
they're doing other things that's a more
complex data structure today I'm talk
about tools a little bit so library that
I right or helped right and it has lots
of tuned of limitations of these kinds
of functions we're talk about this sort
of thing later but as always we can
switch down to some lower level system
like pandas pandas has a nice reduced
accounting system in their series object
so you can see value counts on the
series the value fence method on the
series object is about twice twice the
price to speed okay but notice this is
sort of 2x right it's not 100 x we sort
of expect to get a hundred x speed up
when we switch from Python to something
lower and we're getting to know two to
four depending on how tuned we are you
could even you know compare this with
Java
so here's here's the Java position sort
of straight naive Java code sort of how
you would generally write it and Java
gives you you know a slight speed up not
that much Python is about 225 x slower
than Java win your computations are data
structure bound entering lots of dynamic
getting and catching Richard reversing
data structures Python sort of the one
of the benchmarks I'm showing you here
say that we have sort of the two x 25 x
slow down ok it's not 10 to 100 that's
sort of the vein take away from the top
ok two to five not ten to a hundred all
right so given that in lots of
applications you might actually consider
staying within pure python not using
pandas not using dump I this is like
heresy understand in the pie that the PI
data community but pure python is not
that bad you get lots of things you get
simple accessible data structures you
get lists you get sets it gets two pools
you get dictionaries they're actually
really powerful data structure is a
really powerful abstractions we're very
portable installation is a breeze
there's great library support around
these things you can serialize all of
these out attraction to JSON trivially
right it's hard harder to do that with a
pandas dataframe you can but it's sort
of get to do some extra work so if i
sort of staying in the core you get lots
of extra functionality you get streaming
data structures will talk about laziness
of it I also claim you get easy
parallelism just easy embarrassing prism
you also get a great library for for
streaming analytics or something to talk
about so there's this idea there's lots
of functions that we use on lists that
are useful things like that really find
in itertools so there's lots of
functionality around these coordinator
structures that you might want even ok
in particular in functional languages
languages like like Lisp or scheme or
Haskell right now Scala closure they're
sort of a they often use this this core
data structure idea we're pretty
strongly and they often embrace laziness
and so the set of common functions that
are grown up out of these languages that
have been tested for decades and sort of
always in all these languages and those
functions are very useful for analytics
their rigs for analytics same way that
pandas are a useful analytics but in a
sort of different class of problems
um so this is my favorite function
actually give several talks about this
particular function this is the group by
function so you may be no group by for
SQL or a group buy from pandas this is
grouped by just the function so this
isn't any fancy thing this is just the
function it takes a function as an input
that's kind of weird right that's an
interesting piece and it takes a
collection so here we have just a list
of names and it gives you a dictionary
that groups all the atoms new collection
by their value under that function so
here we've gotten got all the names of
like 30 legs in a 5 and all the lengths
of all the names will thanks Evan so
this is where the core idea behind we
can find independence group I but it's
just just a function right this is are
the thing that's in the functional
standard library that python is sort of
locking Python does have some function
abstractions right we got map got filter
we got reduce nobody likes these right
nobody likes these who actually uses map
day to day all right that's the same
thing will unexpected we got a third of
the room filter and the exact same hands
just went up yeah reduce yeah we got
like five of you yeah and you guys are
hated by your community too right right
so we've replaced these with us
comprehension as we replace these with
sort of just the basic reductions we
find but in annuities are um but there's
others like map filter and reduce have
cousins like really sexy cousins that
you want to hang out with right like
group by group by is a really good
cousin of that filter and reduce you use
group by every day you just don't know
it you knew right interesting code group
buys in there just like how nap is in
there so here's so take and drop our
sort of commonly fountains for the
simple things so take and drop take a
sequence and sort of a number and they
gives you just just a certain length of
that sequence yes we're asking the first
five data or the last five of data I'm
going to interleave some sequences
together we can do the merge part of
merge sort I've been a gun on job
interviews and there's like oh did this
problem like oh that's really
dismembered sorted now you just pull up
pull up these these these
functions so there's lots of different
sequence base functions that you might
find appealing no I'm using list
everywhere because these are all lazy
okay we'll talk about laziness in a
while ah this memoization also really
common sort a functional concept that we
like missing in Python actually adding
LRU cache in funk tools 33 or 34 that's
being added there's things like
dictionary munging right there a very
common function for munging dictionaries
your get a lot of dictionaries with some
data in them and we're summing along all
the all the values so these sort of very
common functions that you you use all
the time you just always end up making
your own your own code occurring in pipe
this little wackier but if your
functional programmer you might like
turning you might like pipe if your
closure enthusiasts you might recognize
that with both of these you can get a
thread laughs macro but that's that's
the scary part of what we're going I'm
going to use pipe of it actually later
on so imma show it off so pipe takes a
bit of data like the number three and
then a sequence of functions and it
applies those functions in turn onto the
data so we take three we double it to
six we double it to 12 we turn into a
string string 12 so sort of a very nice
way to compose lots of functions on a
data so once you sort of have this sort
of grab bag of functions you should have
do lots of lots of analytics in an easy
way so here here's word counting we've
got a function to stem words we're gonna
take our sentence we're going to load it
up we're going to match if we're gonna
stem each word and we call frequencies
on it so I start thinking this way once
you have the sort of set of functions
that claim that you can do most analytic
problems I sort of just a dozen
functions or so two dozen so right to
doesn't function you're sort of set and
again these much has been sort of
refined over years of functioning which
community so i write this library called
pipe tools and they're all in there so
PI tools so there was itertools and funk
tools I claim that they're not complete
so I added new libraries with the Z
instead we all signed dick tools and I
became tools pi tools is composable all
the functions can interact with each
other easily it's lazy we support ladies
with laziness whenever possible
data sets we're all so pure so none of
the functionary side effects pi tools so
I tools this library of all the
functions I just showed you plus you
know a few dozen others all up I tools
is low-tech most functional language
folks will programming things you
planted Python people like get really
excited about some syntax or about like
some wackiness there's like a macros
pine macro pie exists in Python right so
you might like you know this is not
scary this is the non scary functional
programming library and so I'm in claim
they're tuned we've actually benchmarked
all of these or most of them and they're
pretty much at the speed that Python can
handle most this is not my work there's
lot of other people's work there's a
serializable so anything produced by
tools doesn't introduce any civilization
issues this is an interesting point if
you wanna go to parallelism doesn't make
sense to worry about it it's also I
think one of the most mature terms of
software boxes libraries I've seen it's
very very small sort of being easy to
this well 100 test coverage distorted by
Travis CI there we have much more
docstrings we have actual code and
against is it wasn't sort of our design
we just sort of implemented design
that's been around for a long time so
that's in with a numpy inherited from
some root of a PL and that lab the pen
is inherited from our you know we're
just sort of copying what's what's been
out there in other languages these are
contributors the party person started by
myself and John Jacobson and then lots
of their folks came in and all the hard
work we destroyed up set up tests
because Eric will just sort of taking it
over so here's we're counting take file
name open it up straight peach line
split each line to set of words take
each of those lists of words and
counting into one long list of words
Sten each of the words and con
frequencies so this looks natural to me
when I might not look natural to you
sort of it's sort of weird if your
pardon like Clojure before this looks
great but presumably this we're not a
cloture Koecher data so you can still
use these concepts inside of your
standard workflow pipe tools is just a
set of functions so this might look
better Taylor that's fine
okay so here's a slightly more complex
example is the yeast genome I've got
data directory with lots of FA files not
fasta not quite sure yeah fafsa the bio
people the two bio people here knew
there are lots of files in there with
lots of data i think it's it's not so
much the Easter pretty simple we here's
a couple of a couple of the files and
I'm going to produce one long string of
base pairs out of that set of files I'll
stream sort of munching some data I take
my file pattern I get all the file names
I sort them I open each one I drop the
header you might have noticed that there
was a header here that we didn't want
and there's really the same
concatenation and trick and what's nice
is that you know tools is sort of is
lazy by default so we do a little bit of
work and we just pay a little bit I mean
do you know more work we pay slightly
you know slightly more but I'm even
still this is actually quite fast you
know here's a million base pairs out of
this weird final structure in 30
milliseconds so honestly it's a lot of
problems like this probably fast enough
here's a here's a Markov chain so given
a sequence we're going to take each
successive triple of that sequence we're
going to count frequencies I need unlike
you to the tribbles then we're going to
sort of munge them around so we had
things like this we want them to look
like I got wrapped around like that
we're in version all together again this
shouldn't make sense to you right now it
makes sense to me because I know like
the Dozen functions I need to know this
i recommend you learn those dozen
functions too there are nice dozen
functions to know it takes you know
eight seconds not super fast but it's
all right james powell give a great talk
earlier today about generators a mission
teacher I to have composable pieces
right so Markov that's nothing to do
with with the genome sequence we can c
do markov chain on the the words we
found before this idea of composability
is really nice okay um so I was happy
with that eight second time that's
actually pretty close to sort of how
Java would do is sort of 225
right that's sort of the the barrier but
so the second contributor on pi tools
and now honestly the main contributor is
this guy Eric mulch who has been awesome
not only has really benchmarked a lot of
titles but he also reaffirm ented all in
Saipan so I'm not to show you sike tools
which is the same exact function set but
not automated in Python will talk about
how that sort of interesting if you like
this I had heard that that Eric was on
the job market or about to be on the job
market I think so I asked him some asked
him to send me some business cards I
would love for him to County area so if
any company here is the 0 hiring Python
developers maybe one or two out there he
might if you like this you might be
innocent talk about okay so PI tools
provides utility functions for core
Python data structures again we're
talking about lists dicts two pools and
sets when I claim that that's enough for
lots of cases it's port streaming
composition parallelism and they're
pretty fast side tools is the exact same
thing on the exact same chord by thon
data structures but is significant
faster it's actually a cinching project
from a sort of general ecosystem point
of view and that is the first one I know
that completely reimplement seeeeee
another project so the site tools
project satisfies the pipe the pipe
tools test suite perfectly we actually
have tests to make sure the dock streams
are the same so it's a perfect drop in
drop in replacement and so while it uses
see or scythe on its support to notice
that it's actually working on your
dipped and on your list on your tuple so
you don't have to sort of switch out to
any other system so here's we had before
with this this nice genome and when we
just switch out its the import statement
we get the significant speed up and that
notice is again like sort of the two to
five times you're talking about before
so this is actually this is X pretty
nice ashole sanuk that both pi tools and
side tools or pip installable and
trivial they worked on Python to Python
3 is in kolkata base they're easy to use
we had this frequency attachment from
before right we're counting sort of the
you know frequencies of names and side
tools comes at it right about Java
speeds actually depending on when i run
this notebook cycles will be java or not
be java so really if you're using lists
and dictionaries and tuples site tools
competitive with a low-level language
like Java I called avila look which in
this context so this is sort of
interesting right you can actually play
with Python and if you are using
dictionaries in this and tuples it's act
like your space you can use Python
guilt-free right sort of what I've taken
away from this from a numerical
ecosystem perspective sanctions
interesting because we usually either
like deal with Python on Python data
structures or were you see on see data
structures side tool sort of does this
weird mix where it sits see speeds but
on Python data structures so there's no
data structure and penis mismatch now
you wouldn't use I tools to say do
matrix multiply that would be dumb but
you would use it to build a Markov chain
okay um so all right so we can take I
show you the East genome and the code to
compute on the East genome we can do the
exact same thing with human genome which
I thing on my disk is like 10ish
gigabytes or something maybe there's a
lot of files and I'm not sure what's
what I also have no idea what I'm doing
but my the directory that has about 15
gigabytes of text files and this is
doing my genome stuff on lap 15
gigabytes and it runs in about 10
minutes ok so again not super fast but
it is 15 gigabytes my laptop has four
gigabytes of RAM I didn't have to think
about streaming valga rhythm so we're
all to sort of natural naturally fell
out and so here so the data is
interesting there are some files in
there that have some junk in them
there's this n base pair that shows up
and so if you had sort of if you had
known about your problem you could have
done this company's much more easily
sort of a 4 by 4 or a 4 by 4 by 4 array
and they sort of put in numbers but you
wouldn't have been flexible enough to
handle this weird case there's some n so
some missing data happening some weird
that happening
okay one nice things about parallelism
and they were sort of really driving the
recent push behind function programming
is these notions of parallelism and
concurrency and function programming has
a history of handling that well so right
here right so I'm going to slightly
change my computation I used to produce
one long sequence out of all my files
now I'm going to be one sequence out of
each file and compute my markov chain on
that and well back together at the end
so oh there's no speed f right there so
this is a I'm talk about parallel map p
map for a bit and soapy map is just like
map to start out with I want to take my
foul pattern I'm going to compute a
Markov chain on each on each file I'm
then going to merge them together in
this nice way so I'm sort of i'm
distributing the computation on the file
names i get back some markov chains and
then I I reduce them and with this i
know i mean this is just a secret
sequential computation because i've just
renamed p map to map so this is how I
test my code and then I switch out to
using multiprocessing okay and I use the
exact same the exact same command so if
you do so this P map obstructions a
really nice thing to have in order to
use as well you need serialization tools
helps you with that I go to the cool
socks tools ox if you care you can also
you'll switch out to other we go now we
have the full thing either switches i
find i press on parallel most parallel
are Carol l1 times also have some notion
of P map so if you know those you can
just write your standard code and just
sort of annotate the section that you
care about what the peanut and then you
can sort of user aback and you liked so
I got this to run on a with the multi
processing system I got to run on a I
think are using eight cores on a 16-core
machine I gotta to run like two minutes
that was my speed up from like 10 22
eight cores so not bad all right so PI
tools is that it titles is not unique
Python is by design an imperative
language like if you'll read about this
topic he will say negative things not
negative things but will say positive
things about imperative programming
about its readability and about its
simplicity so my design python is not a
function language but it has all the
ingredients to include lots of nice
functional concepts this is not unique
so this sort of standard library or two
you find it lots of languages I
personally like closure hi tools modeled
after closure but you'll find the exact
same set of functions elsewhere but for
make these functions you only really
need to sort of language features you
need functions as first class objects
and you sort of need lazy iterators but
that's all you really need if language
has those things then you can implement
all of these functions and sort of all
the rest of the things that aren't tools
are lots of things and tools so any
language that has these these attributes
you're sort of set so when Python
there's lots of projects that do this FN
pie I think has the most stars on github
just want to check that out funky it
also exists in a sort of fun they've got
a different set of functions but there
are there any set of functions there's
more itertools and there's there's tools
in javascript there's underscored ojs is
probably the most popular example of
this sort of project so what actually
work in JavaScript I just import
underscore and I pretty much right tools
code and it all works out this is really
nice sort of cross language set of
functions that you can use in c-sharp
and the.net platform there's link which
takes more from relational algebra from
sequel than it does from function
analysis functional programming but
that's also sort of a good case of
injecting functional languages into
imperative by design languages I would
love to see this happen in Julia
anyone's active in that it's a good
project to do it's very easy the spec is
already out there I almost actually kind
of interested
java 8 rush everyone knows but Java 8
has functions as for class objects and
they've always had these lazy iterators
so you can imagine John would becoming
much more pleasant to write in or
functional perspective also I'd love to
see that happen to write so I give a
talk at Pied out of New York a tutorial
on sort of why you should like function
programming from a design perspective I
try not to hit the design too much and
talking about performance here but we
should go check that out if the sort of
thing interests you very quickly
functional programming will just make
you a better programmer generally even
if you don't use it in practice
composition in large projects ends up
sort of increasing accessibility and
scalability pure composable functions
are very easy to test by nature sequence
abstractions gave you this sort of
streaming ability like I was able to
compute this genome this large genome on
my small laptop I needed I think like
two kilobytes of data to kilobytes of
RAM it's all it was sort of necessary in
order from the competition and that sort
of falls out going to use these ideas
and the middle so there's this idea of
purity and suits realization for
parallel to show to computing so good
ideas fall out of this paradigm just
look into it réseau pipe tools as
interesting history so I like the
language closure I think you guys should
also like the language closure but
probably you won't no one yeah so one so
I need to interact with CN for troncoso
my sort of day job I interact with
numeric linear algebra that's what did
you normally and Clojure that's that's
not a Gleeman what to do that also my
cuzzo closure is a lisp on the JVM may
be interested to know and for most
people in this room both of those words
are probably ugly certainly my community
lisp and JVM are both like you know
revoltin so so i couldn't could
enclosure but i found i didn't really
need a whole lot of things that were
enclosure i really liked this sequence
abstraction and the standard library i
didn't really need macros not all the
time you know most the function
programming i do that sort of day-to-day
stuff has nothing to do with macros or
known as or algebraic type systems it
just rid of this nice set of functions i
like
so I originally made itertools and funk
tools and dick tools to sort model off
the standard library versions with s in
the name and I sort of imported those
all under tools and then a bunch of
other people came and came by and made
them all faster I routinely get a pull
request like hey you're merge sort of
routine you'll be using the keep q
algorithm in the standard library here
you go it makes it forty percent faster
that's sort of like a standard pull
request Philip last few months in PI
tools and that's it's rare to find a
function that's not faster than PI tools
that you could write yourself this is
the so these people who have helped out
again I said this is a joint project
between John and myself to start out
with the law school came on and then
Eric Welch hopped on and sort of has
taken it sigh tools as large as Eric
Welch and a few new contributors with a
lot of inspiration coming from closure
and from underscore that's it so main
takeaway for data structure bound
computations python is two to five times
slower not ten to a hundred if you just
my patch marks which you should puncture
programming not a bad idea you don't
have to like be scared by it there's
things in funchal programming that you
can like that you know don't require you
to understand type theory there's some
few good ideas that are really the
important ones you should think about
tools of science library just having pip
install tools at some point might make
it life better and I've already use
tools tryouts I tools and everything
just works so nice oh that's it thank
you guys for attention
so that piping example or the pipe
function looks really awesome I was
wondering so I was wondering are you
able to extract an element from the end
of the pipe before you finish processing
the input so for example I gave you like
an infinite generator could I just start
start popping things yeah you can just
say take one take two okay yeah i mean
so all type does you take data you apply
series of functions on to it if those
functions are lazy then you're good okay
I think we've all used like normal map
sort of like I map so with that would
you have to pass in the correct so yeah
so there's a map in tools and it's I map
it's a map in Python too and it's
python3 map in Python 3 so the tool all
tools functions are lazy if they can be
so I'm actually I would I did from tools
import star I actually pulled in I
pulled in the imap if you're in Python 2
yeah so like tools handles the most
things it's also like what I use for pi
2 3 compatibility a lot of times like if
I need a map that's it that's lazy butt
by 12 and five on three it is important
from tools resign as your question yeah
thanks thank you for the talk it's
really interesting i like to see these
concepts oh my question is what's the
relationship between the itertools and
funk tools in the standard library like
if they are it seems like you're doing
it pretty much the same thing but faster
and if that's the case why not put those
in the standard library right yeah so
I'm not only the same thing senators and
funk tools they're all so fast I could
implement in see their great libraries
how did everyone do comet or X for some
sort of permutations thing I go to
itertools there are tools with us great
library I would claim to some things
that are missing a sort of mouse or my
approach if you some functional
programming and you come to them oh
there's like wait this thing is there
nothing isn't there some of these don't
match up and so I think of it er tools
and funk tools as being compliments to
the standard library the second question
was why not contribute this back to the
standard library oh I honestly don't
feel a whole lot of need I think that
the like github and pip pretty much
handle the distribution system for me I
think I suspect that any conversation it
would do wouldn't go into 27 which would
be an issue for me there isn't much of a
need like I think that the dispersion
around Python packaging is sufficient to
distribute this without it being
packaged in the core core system but
it's a valid point it'll brought it on
before you show you the Markov chain
over there it was quick all the time
when you when you show that is it part
of your library or is it something that
you do can you explain explain in a few
words because where is the matrix here
this is where missing so no the social
is not part of tools it's as part of
this presentation what I claim is that
you can you can make relatively complex
operations with a small set of functions
and that's those small sub functions
been refined over decades in the
functional functional paradigm us about
a matrix and this public doesn't
classifies of markov chain exactly but
I'm associating to a pre sequence a
mapping of the next the next element and
account so I'm going to retract my
markov chain claim and i'm just going to
say that i'm counting this go back to
we're almost there right so given a
sequence i make anything like this
that's not going to claim so i'm not
quite sure you mean we mean by matrix
its case but so the results here is that
if i've seen an a and then a tea what's
the next thing i'm about to see and
historically what I've seen is this I've
seen you know three hundred thousand
days to and thousand sees two thousand
GS and 302,000 tease so maybe so maybe
my next thing might be a tier and a
might not be a so that's how fish
sorry so you can divide this little bit
your answer there's a guy over there so
you said in in one of these tests you
had 15 gigs of data with a few kilobyte
memory footprint um I said I could do it
if you kill that memory footprint Oh God
how far do you think you could push this
I mean a terabyte of data I mean I'm
thinking is this a reasonable set of
tools to think about for sort of the
medium data space where you're still
about you have more data than wouldn't
fit in RAM but it's still not you know
like uh sir yeah so um yeah so what I
mean really the the thing I'm leveraging
here is is streaming algorithms right
the idea that you actually don't need to
hold on to all the remember at once you
can sort of walk walk through it I think
that streaming is definitely a good
candidate to handle medium data data
sets because able to compute 15
gigabytes in pure python in with side
tools in 10 minutes if you had a
terabyte you wouldn't mind waiting a few
minutes a few hours you'll be fine so
definitely streaming is a good candidate
for for medium sized data you know
you're just sort of bound by computation
not found about my memory the nature
question yeah thanks great one comment I
would have on this is that you've
implemented functional tools and
imperative language but you haven't
shown us a comparison of functional
tools built in a functional language I
would expect that they're a huge speed
difference between what you're doing
here what you would see in like ml or o
camel or or skiing with chicken or
something like that and so just a
comment if you want to like take this
concept farther actually evaluate what
tools the functional come you actually
use to speed up their code are you
expecting functioning will just be
faster or slower for these operations I
expect them to be faster that is not
been my experience I haven't tested with
the ML family languages I have this list
family languages do a closure a lot and
that's JVM so but if you take like a
chicken's to compiler which it actually
is a compiler on top of these concepts
mm-hmm so that'd be fun so now I haven't
done that so I good good good
opportunity um I don't think that I
would hmm I guess I sort of have some
implicit trust in Java to have
implemented these sorts of things well
enough you're laughing now but I mean
java is job is pretty robust right
they've been lot of eyes working on Java
but not at imagine Alaska limitation or
ocala patient thing faster I i would i
would not expect me ten times faster
looks like we're done oh one more just a
general question um you know a lot of
the benchmarks that you looked at our
doing a lot of string processing and for
some reason maybe this is a bad
intuition I I kind of expected high time
to do a little bit better relatively
sure if you're doing string munching and
I'm just curious what you think things
the high level versus low level be
different to be if you were working on a
numerical set of bytes in python vs
something that was kind of hand coded in
c heights your questions making me sick
ah yeah so oh wow oh yeah I just ah no
so in numerics something like pen is
quite a bit better actually if you get
at numerix oh so I've chosen strings
here for a reason again oh man right so
a good example is if you look at this
operation and you can see you don't have
to do this operation we have done with
these data structures you couldn't
afford a 4 by 4 array of integers if you
see an a you put into the 03 BCAA put
into the 00 slot you know AAT put in 0 0
you know once lot you could do this much
better if you knew numerics ahead of
time you're pretty cool so if you knew
you know the only had four letters
coming in so when you when you switch
down to numerix you get some more you
get more to crunch on right where the
layers can do a lot better job oh so
when you think about a stream
version that runs on numpy arrays are a
wraparound hdf5 would that be a faster
still the same journal ideas oh well
well hon I mean for this sort of
operation if I don't know my words ahead
of time but come out my dad is going to
come in ahead of time then it's hard to
map down to a numpy like system right
I'm really talking about the case where
you're sort of your in this dynamic mode
we can sort of weird data coming in
using Dixon list because you have to if
you don't have to do this please use
numerics like numerics are faster then
you get this sort of 10 then sort of
them in 10 100 x speed up regime but if
you have this sort of like weird
heterogeneous data coming in need to
hell it dynamically my claim is that
python has written this to 25 x regime
when if it is the same experiment with
just pure numbers i think in pandas
value accounts for example they actually
have a separate switch to like do
something else I think numpy dot bin
counts if your elements for frequencies
if your elements are purely unsigned
integers between zero and like whatever
they can do this operation dry very
quickly right then you're in like a
different different auberlen but yeah so
general a general idea like don't do
this we don't have to only do this when
you actually have to and you can if you
understand enough about your problem you
can almost always switch down to the
numeric system right this is what you do
first before you optimize other
questions gross out of time wait one
more yeah
um before this example you had another
one a long one a long sequence in the
pipe you went for it quite fast can you
just go slowly and explain someone who
takes a bit more time to understand
actually what's going on here and each
time and I understand why it's better
but if you can pinpoint where it's much
better than it will help well first of
all I don't plan this is better this is
just different everything a lot of
people would say this is much worse for
my aesthetic I it's it's maybe better
but I would never use the same
production code because people i work
with wouldn't appreciate it okay so pipe
takes a piece of data and then a
sequence of functions and it takes that
data and applies those functions in turn
onto it they turn with closure so
Melissa languages this is the like the
thread lastra thread first macro I use
map here to denote that I want to do
that operation on to everything in the
sequence so I take some file pattern
like some you know some of you might
type into LS to find a list of files I I
sort that list of files I then open each
file okay and notice that this happening
lazily so these are actually open all at
the same time I then drop the first line
of each of those files so drop and take
where these revised life things can you
say lazily again the what does it means
like it doesn't go it goes each file 1
by 10 does it treat them all in parallel
what happens there so a file is like a
sequence and so it's going to open up
one file its going to pull off each line
and so all these things to it and then
it's going to open up another file into
it all the rest of the things but it
will only do that as I asked for
information so if you want this
generally speaking good answers go to
the tools tools don't read the docs org
and there's there's lots of
documentation there about all these
ideas but let's let's talk afterwards I
think there's a longer conversation
we're out of time so thank you guys